استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا يرجع الى اصرار
جميع الاطراف على حل النزاع بالوسائل
العسكريه ومع كل تصعيد تزداد مخاوف وقوع
صدام مباشر بين روسيا والنيتو والذي قد
ينتهي بضربه نوويه واخرى مضاده كل من
موسكو وواشنطن عاملات طيله الحرب البارده
على الاستعداد لهذه اللحظه ورغم عقودا من
الابحاث وعشرات المليارات بقي اعتراض
الصواريخ الباليستيه النوويه مهمه مستحيله
وهنا تركزت الابحاث على ما يسمى بنظام
الانذار المبكر
[موسيقى]
من موسكو نحو واشنطن او العكس الصاروخ
سيبلغ هدفه في اقل من 30 دقيقه والمسار
سيكون في اغلبه في الفضاء ولا توجد حتى
الان انظمه قادره على اعتراضه على هذا
الارتفاع وهنا تبرز اهميه نظام الانذار
المبكر مجموعه من الرادارات الضخمه اي
نشاط ترصد اي نشاط صاروخي مباشره بعد
الاطلاق والولايات المتحده طورت منذ
انتهاء الحرب البارده نظاما يرتبط
بالاقمار الصناعيه وشبكه رادرات نصبت في
اراضي حلفاء روسيا السابقين في الوقت نفسه
خسرت موسكو عده رادارات للانذار المبكر
بسبب تفكك اراضيها وهي كانت في ليتوانيا
اوكرانيا
وهنا جاءت الحاجه لبناء نظام حديث المشروع
لقب ببورونج واعادت روسيا من خلاله
رادارات من سانت شمالا الى البحر الاسود
جنوبا
[موسيقى]
ما اعتبره الكريم لنجدار الحمايه الاول
تحول الى قضيه يشربها الفساد المشكله لا
تتعلق فقط بخساره ملايين الدولارات بل
الاهم هو نظام حمايه غير فعال في زمن
الحرب موقع نانسي متخصص في كشف قضايا
الفساد يسمى المجرمون الروس كشف ان جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي بصدد التحقيق في قضيه
تتعلق برادار بارونج للانذار المبكر
والعيب ليس في التصميم ولا في قدرات
الرادار على الورق بل في الشركه التي
انجزت المشروع
استوردت مكونات لا تصلح للاستخدام العسكري
لما تكلف الا سنتات قليله بدلا من وضع
المكونات المطلوبه التي تكلف مئات
الدولارات واتهم موجهه هنا لشركتين اي اف
كيستيما وارتي اي جي اس سي وهناك اخفاق
اخر ايضا تحديث الرادارات لم يشمل النظام
الطنط التنسيق والانذار وهو ما يشبه
مشاهده افلام فائقه الدقه عبر شاشات قديمه
هذا الفساد ليس هو فقط ما يعوق مجهود
روسيا الحربي صمود علمائها الكبار امام
الاغراءات الغربيه ايضا ظاهره تعود للحرب
البارده لكنها امتدت لتشمل علماء اهم
برنامج عسكري تكنولوجيا الصواريخ فرط
الصوتيه ومن مهد كنجال معهد سيبيريا
للميكانيك النظريه والتطبيقيه الامن
الروسيه اعتقل العالمان اليكساندر شيبليو
واناطولي مازالوب الصيف الماضي بتهمه
تسريب اسرار عسكريه للخارج اداره المعهد
عجبت من القرار بحجه ان العالمين لم
يشاركا الا في نشر ابحاث في مجلات علميه
بموافقه السلطات الامنيه الا ان الرد جاء
الاسبوع الماضي باعتقال عالم ثالث من
المعهد بيليريا
عالم مختص في ديناميك الهواء متهم بتسريب
معلومات سريه للصين اداره المعهد اكدت انه
غير قادر على العمل بدون ابرز علمائه حذر
من هجره ادمغه وشيكا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات